so what's going on with you you're out
of wrestling you were a very successful
wrestler for years as Cactus Jack and
and for years is mankind yes and now all
of a sudden you stop why after I wrote
this book yeah have a nice day I was
like God I really have nothing left to
do in wrestling and I'd had a very
physical style and I was kind of paying
the price people told me 15 years ago
you're never going to last kid you can't
do that stuff yeah what kind of stuff
were you doing that was really hurting
you you know a lot of it was things that
weren't risky but they were painful to
do Time After Time After Time like I
used to do the moves that were normally
done in the ring and take them out of
the ring right the feeling was then if I
get backdropped in the concrete and
everybody hears my body Splat then
they're going to think this match was
real right now nobody thinks it's any
more real than it was when that was in
your mind in my mind right so now so was
your body are you really messed up I
mean what are your pains every day you
know they're uh I guess they're probably
equivalent to somebody who played
football for 15 years yeah the knees are
bad what happens in the morning when you
wake up uh it takes a little while to to
get going really yeah one of your ears
was partially ripped off right you had a
picture of that for a long time you know
how did that happen well that happened I
was in a match in Germany with a guy
named Vader and I was doing a move where
I used to get my head caught up in the
ropes yeah I was the only guy who would
do it because it would hurt like the ear
had already been stitched up like five
or six times right and a bunch of
zippers back there uh and so you could
say that it was a dumb thing to continue
doing but it was like I'm a pretty
physically limited guy and that was my
move because no one else would do it you
were limited because you're a heavy guy
heavy and you know yeah I could I was
not one of those guys who did real well
on the presidential physical fitness
test right right right people pull upset
type of thing so I did this move and
it's like all of a sudden I was like I
couldn't get out you know and the ropes
got tied up ropes were around my neck
and I mean I'm not trying to exaggerate
when I say I was in big trouble because
you thought you were going to not be
able to breathe right what happens if it
keeps putting putting that pressure on
your uh carotid arteries you know you'll
pass out and then who knows if they
would have got me out or not right so
when I pulled out it more or less took
the the Rope which is an elevator cable
wrapped in rubber coating and it just
kind of pushed that ear off the uh off
my head
ah the whole ear came off uh about
two-thirds of it the thing was like any
any other sport you know you're gonna
was that a sound effect yeah that's your
ear coming off
do you have hearing trouble what
do you have hearing trouble no actually
I don't the biggest problem I have is
that I cannot fulfill my uh ambition of
being a carpenter why I can't put the
pencil behind that all right and I can't
I can't wear it's bad right yeah right I
can't wear sunglasses uh but it's not
that bad when your ear rips off they
take you to the hospital they sew it
back on you just don't even have an ear
this was right after the John Wayne
Bobbitt thing right so I I wasn't that
worried and a matter of fact we wrestled
another couple minutes did they find
your ear because yeah you got it what
happened was it was kind of a unique
scenario because the um we had two
referees we were over in Germany two
referees had been injured and sent home
referees so they brought up a guy from
France over who spoke no English yeah so
you can see it was on a handheld video
it wasn't a commercial videotape uh I
got back in the ring and I knew I was
hurt because the blood was kind of
pouring down on the match you know and I
could kind of hear it you know hitting
the map oh my God I got back in the ring
and I knew I knew I was hurt but I
didn't know I didn't know how bad and so
you see it you know I blocked uh this
guy Vader's punch I threw one of my own
and the ear just fell off to the candle
wow the fans must have loved that yeah
but the referee now didn't speak any
English so he couldn't tell me I have
your ear so he then handed it to the
ring announcer who brought it to the
back and so as soon as this match is
over a couple minutes later I go ah let
me check out oh God it's gone you know
see what you're saying is kind of
interesting and what I always felt about
it you know while then everyone saying
oh gee wrestling's fake it's still to to
pull off the stunts right it is the hard
part especially if you make it look real
oh it's like you know especially if you
don't know what you're doing which you
clearly didn't because you have to take
a razor blade and cut yourself it's been
a long time since I had to do that type
of thing but even still that's got to
take its toll I finally smart enough I
was having a match with the Undertaker
right right it was mankind no one really
knew what I looked like underneath the
mask
and at that time not a people not a lot
of people did even only the people who
knew I was Cactus Jack so I thought you
know we'll have the mask come off and
I'll be like scarred underneath it right
so what I did is when I was driving to
the show a day earlier I had a piece of
sandpaper and I was taking my skin off
with the sand thing wow
this is where the makeup comes in no
wonder they love the guy I'm wrestling
you know he I burnt them before yeah
with the with uh with special flash
paper and he went to the makeup artist
and then had a burn put on and I had a
real one and his look better than mine
really I was like oh you know I mean
there is a secret to this type of thing
foreign